bonjour et bienvenue dans une vidéo de
castets incroyablement jolie la tesla
box la boîte tesla c'est andy gill coeur
qui nous a envoyé un mail en disant
voilà j'ai la boite de tesla chez moi
bon c'est lui qui l'a construite des
casse-têtes faut que ça vive j'ai voulu
l'envoyer ça vous dit nous on aide
jérémy delà reçues il la montée et
aujourd'hui on va se la faire je ne
comprends pas déjà de l'intelligence des
gens qui sont capables de créer des gros
casse-tête mais surtout quand ils ont en
plus le talent mécanique pour créer tout
ça bref c'est très joli j'ai un petit
mot comme ça qui accompagne la botte de
tesla et merci andy gill coeur j'ai le
coeur odile coeur on sait pas trop
comment se dit son nom de famille tout
est secret avec lui je mettrai sur
facebook et son site internet dans la
description
[Musique]
alors commençons 90 minutes une à trois
personnes difficultés modérées bon ça
veut dire que comme je suis tout seul je
mets mes trois fois 90 minutes j'espère
que non samedi le 8 juin 1901 la ville
est plongée dans la noirceur
l'électricité s'est arrêtée soudainement
la nuit dernière pendant la nuit de
vendredi à samedi les lumières de la
ville se sont soudainement éteinte les
patients devaient rentrer chez eux dans
l'obscurité la population a peur nikola
tesla test l'électricité gratuite nikola
tesla et son équipe n'en faut que je le
dise avec la voix des journalistes
nicolas tesla et son équipe ont
travaillé sur un concept qui pourrait
éclairer tout le continent en un instant
et gratuitement nikola tesla est
introuvable cette thématique peut être
résolu seuls ou en équipes de deux ou
trois personnes fait fonctionner la
boule de plasma le cas cette thématique
est résolu lorsque la musique jouée que
la boîte de plasma est activée ensuite
j'ai la boule de bois avec un doit
toucher la boule avec un doigt pour un
effet amusant isolez pas cette phrase
connexion internet à proximité pour
résoudre le casse-tête thématique hier
ben voilà écoutez il ya un petit truc là
que je vois déjà c'est qu'il ya des
lettres en majuscules dans tout ce
paragraphe donc atr au
psg om fait l e ceni troll est ce que ça
veut dire qu'il ya rien d'autre
probablement bon c'est parti phase
d'exploration on a ça j'imagine faudra
pal devi c'est là il ya un petit bouton
un oeuf messager touche pas c'est pour
ça que jérémy a communiqué avec le
créateur pour savoir ce que j'avais le
droit de toucher ou pas là on a trop ces
trois boutons là là on a un petit
téléphone
de l'autre côté
je crois que j'ai fini le cas cette
saison il faudra composer un truc
et u22
ben voila je loue et là il ya une sorte
de grosse boîte grosse clé qui m'a l'air
de pouvoir être sorti je vais essayer de
la sortir
ou pas ou peut-être qu'il faut plus la
rentrée
voilà à tanger un petit haut il ya un
truc là dedans ok il ya la clé volts
il ya un petit pétillon ses histoires
avec un petit papier dedans petit papier
qui nous dit us 45 46 22 e année est-ce
que c'est l'année d'un dossier attends
je vais regarder comme sur le petit mot
de départ il y avait marqué qu'il
fallait une connexion internet il faut
peut-être faire de la recherche en temps
réel us 45 et 46 hommes 2 1 est-ce que
ça me sert quelque chose system of
electric lightning c'est pas pour rien
ça nikola tesla à [ __ ] ça des brevets
tesla 1891 donc 91 peut-être je peux
composer ça ici
ok il s'est passée sa salle je reviens
de secondes dessus mais c'est très
satisfaisant vous vous n'avez pas connu
peut-être sur mon compte est ce que vous
êtes né mais moi mon téléphone fixe chez
mes parents ils étaient vraiment comme
ça quand il y avait que dix chiffres
numéro de téléphone avant genre à la
rochelle c'était 46 01 38 26 par exemple
et donc tu composes est ton numéro de
téléphone comme ça après il ya eu
l'arrivée des 0 5 0 n'a donc ça faisait
dix chiffres je peux te dire que quand
tu te faisais les 10 chiffres et qu'en
plus il ya beaucoup de 8 2,7 et 2,9 dans
le numéro et que dernier tu disais à ma
mère me suis trompé c'était souvent de
tout refaire jérémy tu as eu ça toi
c'était très très chiant de tout refaire
ça
assise à ce trou il fallait que je veux
que la séquence que j'ai vu là des
lumières il fallait peut-être que je le
refasse après avec les trucs je vais le
refaire
11,3
pas du tout mais comme il n'y a pas
grand chose à part ça pour moi il faut
que je fasse en fonction de ça ou alors
il faut juste que lui soit en haut pour
allumer et lui est un plus et l inverse
enfin je me dis que allumé sans nommer
personne personne n'a dit ce genre de
choc
[Musique]
c'est passé c'est pas c'est pas très
très clair il ya un truc que je peux
essayer c'est d'écrire volts avec le
téléphone en gros c'est un truc qu'on
utilise souvent dans les énigmes pour
donner un code chiffré par exemple tu
vas dire un mot époque-là personnel se
disent sur un téléphone où est-ce qu'ils
étaient les lettres ou est-ce qu'elles
sont encore parce que vous savez ici si
tu voulais faire un ses avants sur les
anciens téléphones t'appuyer trois fois
sur la touche une parce que ça faisait
abc donc je vais essayer d'écrire volts
peut-être juste en quatre lettres pas de
faire
trois fois guide pour avoir levé mais
juste de faire la touche où il a levé la
touche de haut la touche duels et la
touche du thé je vais essayer ça donc ça
ferait d'ailleurs ça ferait quoi
86 58
81 6 50
ok
comment c'était flippant mais moi j'ai
cru qu'ils allaient me péter à la gueule
là ok donc là ça m'a animé l du coup les
deux étaient allumés du coup elles se
sont emballées elles se sont éteintes
donc je pense qu'il y avait deux étapes
en fait il y avait la première étape
c'était 1891 pour allumer elle la 2e
étape c'était volts pour allumer elle
est qu'une fois que les deux sont
allumés il passa une séquence suivante
c'est à peu près ce que ça m'inspire
passons à la suite alors si elle se
trouva de la suite c'est avec les petits
bitonio kiala parce que j'ai libéré tous
les indices j'ai rien de spécial qui
s'est ouvert peut-être que je remets la
crimée on ne peut
pas de choses spécifiques là dedans ça
c'est pas d'elie saab démontable des
choses comme ça non il marque est quand
même déçu la peau de tesla opérateurs je
vois que vous allez vous abonner à cette
chaîne youtube et ça me fait extrêmement
plaisir je vois également que l'on
approche des deux millions d'abonnés je
vois également que j'ai les deux dg
vraiment la dalle faut qu'on arrête de
tourner juste avant de manger de cg
c'est assez étrange pour moi d'avoir si
peu d'exploration à faire donc je vais
réessayer toupet combinaison
il est marrant ce casse-tête à avoir si
peu de en fait l'un des casse tête où il
ya la limite trop de choses et donc on
sait pas trop quoi où on passe à côté de
choses à fouiller là on passe à côté de
rien c'est en fait la clé le seul
élément mobile donc pour moi soit c d e
mais peu importe et position il se passe
rien et si j'avais une séquence j'aurais
pas le deviner on voit avec jeanne
indices là je vois pas ce qu on pourrait
essayer mais dès que je fais un 4
chiffres il se passe rien alors que tout
à l'heure même quand je faisais 1,4
chiffre qui était pas bon il se passait
quand même un truc donc il nous reste
que ça on amovible j'ai besoin de voir
comment c'est fait est ce que on peut la
mettre dans ce sens
cette fois c'est le truc dans la vie
parce qu'en fait là il ya comme il ya
comme de l'aluminium là dessus du coup
je me demande si ça doit pas faire
contacter quelque part
il se passe pas grand chose à l image ça
se passe dedans mais bien entre ou
pourtant je pensais quand l'enfant
semblait se passerait quelque chose qui
est dit titre dans les commentaires
pourtant je suis bien dans le four
fait on atteint le stade où tu commences
à faire des trucs je sais c'est le stade
où tu peux dire ah ça rentre pas là mais
je vais essayer et en fait ça rende pas
là mais tu as besoin d'essayer pour le
savoir non moi je suis très très
perturbé par cette serrure et cette clé
qui potentiellement ça m'a servi à quoi
ça m'a servi à virer ça et donc ça m'a
permis de trouver ça ça ça m'a permis
d'allumer l'autre en poule avec le mot
volts dans la logique on ne peut
continuer par là
essayer avec la lumière il est lunettes
ça c'est un peu ma tenue de super héros
celle inverse une superman clark kent
lui devient superman sans ses lunettes
moi j'ai besoin de lui
[Musique]
la marche le fonds peut pas tellement
plus profond que ça
opérateur opérateurs j'ai un ami j'ai
enfoncé une clé au fond de la nuit
j'ai farfouillé au fond du fond en bas
en haut à gauche et à droite il se passe
rien est ce que je fais fausse piste ou
est-ce que potentiellement quelque chose
ne marche pas attendait parce que j'ai
quand même la consigne que comme c'est
un os made qui existent en pièces
uniques a peut-être si je me demande si
quelque chose est cassé ça vaut le coup
de demander vous écoute opérateurs donc
c'est sûr la bonne étoile
[Musique]
je changeais de clés pour le principe
part de médias y en a une qui marchent
luc l'autre sinon je vais [ __ ] de
l'aluminium là dedans ce que je crois
que ces deux là lui qui fait la
rencontre une dernière fois mais
[Musique]
nous sommes de retour parce que oui nous
étions partis un moment donné parce que
le chef opérateur j'ai remis les partis
acheter de l'aluminium et nous avons
entouré la clé d'aluminium afin que le
point de contact soit tout autour de la
clé
verdict si ça marche pas on abandonne en
fin du mois en abandonnant le renvoi aux
créateurs et vous vous verrez la suite
de la vidéo ici mais il y aura peut-être
des semaines qui s'écouleront
ok là ça tourne en continu je lâche pas
la clé j'ai pas confiance 1 2
attends je compte mal de ma tête
1-2 je compte les cliques 2 1 si je
bouge ça
à temps c'est plus la même séquence
il n'ya plus que 1 et il ya deux là
c'est comme un master mind en fait
c'est génial
là je suis revenu à 2 1 ok donc il faut
se dire qu'il y en a un qui dit qui dit
ce qu'il ya de bon et l'autre qui dit ce
qui est faux la difficulté c'est qu'on
sait pas quel ampoules me dit combien at
bon et qu'elle a en tout ne me dit
combien il y en a de faux mais ça c'est
pas grave il suffit en fait de se dire
une des deux doit être allumé trois fois
et après tu constates s'il se passe un
truc ou pas en fait je vais lever le
tout dernier
ok donc lâché la position inverse de
départ effectivement elles ont switché
donc pour tout début ça faisait 2
et 1
quand j'ai levé la ça fait 2 vient donc
je vais bouger sur celui du milieu ce
coup-ci
1 2
donc là a priori tout est faux
donc on inverse et on va essayer de
mettre les trois là maintenant
donc là on revient sur le 2-1 en temps
normal
c'est ça là je relève lui ça me faisait
d'eux ici et un
l'a12 lui je le touche pas donc lui je
vais me relever 1 2 3
et il se passe quelque chose comme tout
à l'heure ça me fait peur bon bah je
pense que c'est une fin d'étape fin de
la deuxième étape
elle va tourner dans pas longtemps
apparemment
ok c'est pas mal on s'en sort pas mal on
a réussi la deuxième étape après qui
d'une heure de galère juste deux points
de contact ah non c'est pas moi qui fais
le contact en fait ça fait 4 3 2 et là
ça va faire quoi 1 j'ai l'impression
qu'il ya eu à peu près le même délai
près un nom un deux trois
4 si je vais faire sur le téléphone 4
[Musique]
la ce a validé quelque chose moi certain
temps ça va trop vite pour moi je crois
que j'ai validé un truc en mettant dans
le téléphone le prochain code c'est
quand je leur rends plaque 1 2
ok je me valider une deuxième chose
il a refait deux
hoquets
fin de 3e étape
voilà quand les trucs sont connectés que
ça fait contact ils vivent à outils
carthage et je me suis baladé sur la
troisième étape
ça a fait clic clic
clic
le bouc
j'ai pas compris
ça fait deux ça va pas être la même
chose je le fais par acquis de
conscience
attend des fois ça fait plus le poids ça
peut être les yeux ça fait plus long
ceux du morse je vais chercher un papier
un crayon et des nouveaux yeux aussi
parce que ces lumières elle met quelques
règles
[Musique]
m
la fin je me fais avoir à chaque fois
faut que j'attende encore leur la
séquence qui me fait me faire avoir
scellé clic à deux clics et j'ai envie
mettre deux points alors que c'est juste
un à l'image et thenia je vais me faire
des petites coche sur ce qui est bon et
puis à force je la main
alors l'on courant à dorval nom court
après c'est d'être court court
et après ça doit être plus long cours
non
après c'était un os donc trois longs
après c'est là où je peux le dire
maintenant long cours cliffs courcoult
reprise longs courts longs trois longs
s'il te plaît court long court court
après court long court court long cours
pour long cours on suit la conversion
alors on commence par un n ensuite ça
nous fait un hic à ça commence à me
faire peur unique et vous
nico aubin c'est d'être nicolas
ça c'est un mot ça ça doit être un tel
compte répond poi poi poi traiterait
points points en gros les lettres en
morse c'est entre le 1 et 3 signe les
chiffres c'est toujours 5 et les autres
ce qui ponctuent à sion et
cc6 donc je pense que ces six pas je
pense que c'est de la ponctuation 10
contre 11 points 13 points
d'interrogation ok donc c'est nicolas
prendre interrogations nicolas point
d'interrogation
ben voilà de terminer j'ai envie
d'essayer de le taper là mais là ça me
paraît trop simple parce que la séquence
dan en avant il ment pas si ça vaut le
coup d'essayer mais le point
d'interrogation
nico licol nicolas pour l'interrogation
0 1
non
[Musique]
ça fait quoi si je le convertit
d'ailleurs saint nicolas
alors le point d'interrogation serait un
calcul à faire
nicolas d'interrogation nicolas denis
juste a dit hier j'ai vu nicolas
tesla
[Musique]
tu vois il faut poser la question qu'on
veut avoir la réponse
et eux
s mais ça fait simple elle a
damned c'est quoi cette réponse nul de
nice nicolas
but de sow cela a
peut-être laissé le code se terminer il
ya une séquence il ya un blanc entre les
deux cycles de code que je trouvais trop
long je l'essayé à à la fin de la
séquence tepeu s
elle a
peut-être trompé t e
attends c'est pas le mort cela il est
vraiment très cool il est très joli très
cool à part cette histoire de clés qui
m'a cassé la tête durant une heure
[Musique]
auj
j'avais une boule comme ça quand j'étais
petit j'essaie de tous les réunir en un
pour faire un gros arc comme ça c'est
magnifique très satisfaisant à faire
effectivement en solo ou à plusieurs
c'était très très cool merci beaucoup a
dit d'avoir fabriqué ça nous l'avoir
envoyé ses champs mais bravo quel talent
vraiment quel talent je vais faire ça
jusqu'à la fin de la vidéo comme ça
merci à vous d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
vous en met deux autres à regarder qui
sont deux autres casse tête que l'on m'a
fabriqué est exactement comme ça sur le
principe de petits créateurs qui fait
des pièces uniques ou des petites
quantités je vous mets le site dandy
dans la description encore une fois
parce que puisque merci à lui si vous
cherchez des casse-têtes abordable vous
me le demandez souvent dans les
commentaires je vous recommande le site
de l'insoluble il a tout les rêves il
est très sympa et tout même si vous avez
question sans acheter chez lui il a la
gentillesse de vous répondre donc je
prends ça je le mets en avant et puis
ben moi je vous remercie d'avoir regardé
cette vidéo c'est très intime ma manière
de parler aujourd'hui je sais pas
pourquoi prenez soin de vous à très
bientôt ciao